[Music]
based on a survey i haven't conducted
over 80% of you wish you could change
your username on playstation network
fortunately according to the website per
square Sony actually are conducting a
survey where they're reportedly
exploring the possibility of adding a
feature to PSN that lets users change
their ID given I grew up in the age
where emo was really big and
subsequently many of the usernames I
chose that 11 years old are Blackheart
at which I am supportive of this
possibility sony has never allowed
anyone to change their PSN name to date
but according to this new survey players
would be able to change their PSN ID
multiple times for free but only once
every six months under the proposed
system if you changed your name and
wanted to revert to your original tag
you would have to hit up Sony's customer
support team push squares report doesn't
suggest whether more name changes would
incur fee or what that fee might be by
comparison Microsoft lets you change
your xbox live gamertag once for free
while additional changes incur a fee
before I let those of you with user
names like shootie cool face 420 get
your hopes up there the survey does
state we can't be sure whether this
feature will be added or not but we can
be sure your opinions on the matter will
be heard at the last PlayStation
experience in December PlayStation boss
Shawn Layden said that he hopes in a
year's time there will be an answer to
whether a PSN name changing feature will
be implemented let me know if your
childhood username is worse than mine in
that comment box and I will catch you
next time
you